bonjour c'est un retour à botanique
ouais bonjour à toutes et à tous nos
invités c'est s'exprime déjà en direct à
à l'antenne pour ce face à la première
réalisée aujourd'hui par paul eric tous
à 1 face à la première consacrée à
l'agriculture martiniquaise à la suite
d'un salon matnik agri qui s'est tenu le
week-end dernier
nous envisageons avec nos invités bien
les pistes de développement de
l'aviculture martiniquaise et notamment
comme le thème de ce salon agriculture
et l agriculture durable et diversifiée
nous envisagerons avec eux quelles sont
les raisons d'espérer justement une
telle agriculture pour notre pays dans
les années à venir je commence par donc
madame myriam re clair bon jour en jour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vous êtes exploitante agricole
secrétaire général du syndicat jia
jeunes agriculteurs l'antenne de
martinique et entre 2010 et 2015
vous avez occupé la fonction de chef du
service politique agricole
alex conseil régional voilà et notre
autres invités et christian d'agir déjà
bien connus bonjour crise honda bonjour
bonjour bonjour bertrand et bonjour les
auditeurs de martinique premier ouais
alors vous êtes agriculteurs
horticulteurs serait exactement c'est
exactement à cette précision
horticulteurs donc fait dans les fleurs
alors bonne question parce que
l'horticulture comprend quatre métiers
la floriculture labro culture en
emmental et la boucle du aux frontières
et la culture maraîchère ce sont les
métiers de l'horticulture d'ailleurs
l'horticulture et est une profession par
amicaux d'accord très bien mais donc ce
ne sont pas que le que les fleurs
il peut y avoir des fleurs alors vous
êtes membre de l'opam l'organisation
patriotique des agriculteurs de
martinique où des agriculteurs
martiniquais donc c'est une c'est un
syndicat plutôt paysans on va dire ça
comme ça laisse oui localisant esprit
l'origine mais l'origine des paysans et
les paysannes et les paysannes est là
elle a une forte comme dirait un fort
ancrage politique ne met pas une
politique quoi une politique agricole 2
tonomy de suffisance alimentaire
ces pam au départ il sait que ça
continue et d'ailleurs aux mails et qui
a été un président emblématique a
beaucoup véhicules et cela et qu'on
regarde bien nous sommes des il y est
normalement tous les îliens devrait
avoir l'esprit de l'autonomie donc
l'opam car glaire à notre le pam le
permettent un syndicat qui regroupe que
des petits exploitants on peut dire ça
comme ça ou c'est ce serait trop
caricaturé alors auparavant ce n'était
que des petits exploitants
aujourd'hui il ya des petits exploitants
bien entendu parce qu'ils se sentent ils
se sentent à l'aise il y a des moyens
exploitants
et puis à quelques gros exploitants qui
ont envie de venir bon mais je pense
qu'ils feront ils feront le pas voilà
bon du moment qu'on a l'esprit paysans
avaient ils ont l'esprit paysans auquel
christian d'agir non membres de l'opam
également administrateur du parc naturel
de martinique et puis vous êtes membres
au titre de votre syndicat au pas mais
aussi à titre personnel vous l'avez
également précisé vous êtes membre du
collectif 0 chlordécone zéro pesticide
cedex collectif qui vient qui vient de
se créer et qui en pleine action en ce
moment alors je le disais on va partir
de de ce salon matnik matnik agri qui a
duré trois jours
première édition de ce salon de
l'agriculture organisée par la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
en partenariat avec la la chambre
d'agriculture est donc l'objet c'était
d'exposer la pluralité de notre monde
agricole
pendant trois jours il y a eu du monde
manifestement tout cas c'est ce que la
ctm 10 et est d'ailleurs cette semaine
le président du conseil exécutif alfred
marie-jeanne s'est enorgueilli que plus
de 24 mille visiteurs se soient déplacés
vers ce salon qui étaient installés au
stade à liqueur à fort de france
mais rien de clair j'ai pas si vous êtes
allé faire un tour à ce salon peut-être
vous y étiez vous-même exposantes je ne
sais pas en tout cas qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
et est-ce qu effectivement pour vous
c'est un salon qui a connu un franc
succès alors personnellement je n'y ai
pas été
maintenant je vais parler au nom du
syndicat que je représente donc les
jeunes cadets culture de martinique
nous avons une actualité très marquée au
mois de mai y de joints puisqu'on a eu
le congrès national des indiens
donc ce qui fait d'ailleurs que la
présidente est toujours en france
accompagné du secrétaire générale
adjointe puisqu'il fallait aller
défendre les amendements pour le rapport
d'orientation 2018-2020 donc opposer la
présidence et et madame anaïs janvier
chardon voilà et nous n'avons pas
souhaité en tous les cas les gia
martinique n'ont pas souhaité s'associer
à cette édition
pour plusieurs raisons la première c'est
que nous estimons que le contexte actuel
de l'agriculture en tous les cas est
vraiment défavorables et mettre autant
d'argent dans un salon à l'anc
il ya des agriculteurs qui ne
s'installent pas qu'ils ne trouvent pas
de foncier et des agriculteurs qui sont
déjà installés qui met la clé sous la
porte
je trouve nous avons trouvé ça au niveau
des jeunes agriculteurs de martinique
indécent et descend notamment par
rapport à la catastrophe marien il ya
des agriculteurs qui ne sont toujours
pas indemnisé à lanquais la collectivité
régional de la guadeloupe a mis 4
millions d'euros sur la table pour
parvenir à aider justement les paysans
les agriculteurs à se relever de cette
catastrophe
ici nous faisons salon on se pose des
questions autre chose on a une crise on
traverse la crise du chlordécone avec
ben une population qui est aux abois qui
manque un manque de confiance vis-à-vis
de delà des cultures je ne vois pas là
encore pourquoi faire un salon rassurons
la population mettons des entiers en
place construisons des schémas de
développement durable et puis après on
verra si on fait ou pas la promotion de
nouveaux systèmes un d'école là ce n'est
pas le cas des coopératives qui aussi
sont en train de mettre la clé sous la
porte
il ya pléthore de coopérative
maintenions toutes les difficultés du
monde à trouver même des fois cent mille
euros
mille et quelques euros des fois pour
payer des agriculteurs et vous faites un
salon à plus de 600000 euros
nous on trouve que c'est lamentable sous
cette mandature longtemps que j on n'a
jamais été reçue nos doléances n'ont
jamais été entendus ça fait quatre ans
que des dossiers sont bloqués au niveau
européen enfin il ya toute une liste de
raisons qui font qu'aujourd'hui on ne va
pas la promotion de quelle agriculture
qu'ils ont voulu faire
est ce que en fait c'était une
procession
je ne dirais pas un mensuel mais pas
loin
pas loin parce que si on continue comme
ça il restera plus beaucoup
d'agriculteurs en martinique et on ne va
pas non plus donner envie aux jeunes de
s'installer
voilà pour votre sentiment votre analyse
également bien argumenté d'ailleurs
myriam clair à propos donc de de ce
salon qui pour vous donc été
complètement décalées voire même si le
terme que vous avez utilisé indécent par
rapport au budget que que ça a coûté que
ça implique et christian d'agir vous
vous êtes allez vous y étiez
non mais comme ça non c'est trop
personnel
non mais je souris parce que je ne
souris pas pour me moquer je souris
parce que je saurai pas non plus pour
prendre ça à la légère je souris comme
un chinois j'avais les chinois sourice
et puis ils vous coupe la tête quand
même bon donc je souris c'est un sourire
jaune gpo beaucoup beaucoup apprécié
l'intervention devient vraiment là à
l'instant d'alès oui je ne suis pas
allée où ça je suis passé à l'os à l'an
passé j'avais beaucoup travaillé sur mon
exploitation
donc je ne vais pas aller à gaza
100 c'est un élément en plus de ça mon
collaborateur s'étant blessé donc
j'étais amené nous sommes rattrapés du
travail autant plus ferme à part et sa
part donc je ne suis pas à notre sens
c'est un élément deuxième élément je
serais allé voir et cela m'a pas dérangé
n'a pas avoir été au salon pourquoi
parce que j'ai eu des retours et le
retour contrairement à ce qui est dit
les retours de deux collègues lutter
myriam et bien ce sont ces retours là
n'ont pas été des retours satisfaisant
des retours très interrogatif non et ils
vont dans le sens que viennent
développer milliards et boutons c'est
pas des retours de jeu des agriculteurs
et des retours d'agriculteurs qui ont 60
70 ans donc dès qu'ils sont en activité
toujours
et heureusement alors il faut savoir que
vingt-quatre mille visiteurs
c'est ce qui est annoncé non mais moi je
ne vais pas critiquer oui votre 4000
viseur mais il faut savoir que le salon
d'avant il y avait eu 65 mille visiteurs
voilà comment voilà pour mon moi je vais
à suffit pas de 24 mille visiteurs oui
24 visiteurs ok vous avez raison je n'en
disconviens pas mais n'empêche que le
savon d'avant il y avait soixante cinq
mille visiteurs
donc c'est là où il faut se poser des
questions 2 mai a menti à montbrison
l'agriculture est en peau de chagrin
alors ça ne vient pas spécifiquement des
élus politiciens mais ça vient et je me
lepillier ne pas tout de suite ça vient
d'un mot de politique agricole donc la
chambre consulaire agricole il ya un
manque de politiques agricoles et et
c'est terrifiant c'est terrifiant
donc ce qui fait que les élus qui sont
là et bien attention je ne suis pas leur
avocat il faut comme bon leur semble ils
sont à l'aise à faire comme bon leur
sens parce qu'en face il n'y a rien du
tout vous demandez à part des paroles
très ambigu et c'est megan a été très
claire elle était nette à l'été précise
vous me prenez donc voilà voilà
et puis et puis c'est vrai c'est vrai
qu'on soit jeune ou moins jeune les
agriculteurs à l'heure actuelle qui ont
besoin qu'ils frappent à la porte mais
pas comme des mendiants puisque c'est un
c'était une institution qui est là pour
pouvoir permettre aux uns et aux autres
quelles que soient leurs secteurs
économiques doivent d'être d'être
boostée et bien ils ont zéro réponse ça
il faut le dire
vous comprenez donc ces deux scandales
alors vous a été l'occasion de critiquer
effectivement notamment la chambre
consulaire mais on n'a pas compris d'une
manière générale les autorités quoi qui
préside un petit peu à l'agriculture
martiniquaise donc pour vous il n'y a
pas de plan n'y a pas de programme n'y a
pas de de deux visions de élaboré c'est
ça mais les programmes n'ont pas il n'y
a pas de politique mais c'est vrai qu'il
ya pas de politique nous sommes en
martinique nous sommes des îliens ne
vais pas les syndicats agricoles mais il
n'y a pas de politique agricole adapté à
la martinique
tout ce que vous entendez dire c'est que
il ya des plans de subventions par an si
des pans de subventions par là etc
mais ça c'est quoi ce sont des déchets
maquis ont été vomi un ouais j'ai des
plongées déjà des paroles dures
salariale et la situation n'est pas rose
et d'aidés qui ont été vomi et puis qui
sont répétés mais mais mais où est le
discours wade avant qu'il ya un discours
déjà où elle a pensé l'analyse est plein
discours qui colle à la réalité
martiniquaise 0 monsieur 0 vous
comprenez 0 mais rien ne requiert donc
pour vous c'est être à côté de la plaque
que de dire que enfin de mettre en avant
cette thématique pour l'édition 2018 de
se maintenir à gries les agriculture
durable en martinique diversité et
perspectives
tout ça dans une nécessaire prise en
compte des problématiques
environnementales et des risques majeurs
alors ça fait bien couché sur le papier
c'est vrai mais de manière concrète
baisse de manière concrète nous ce que
nous aurions aimé c'est un
accompagnement par rapport justement à
l'après crise marien par exemple de
manière concrète c'est à dire qu' on ne
peut pas employer jusqu'en vous le dites
si on vous le disait si bien des maux et
puis que ce ne soit pas suivie d'actions
les mots c'est bien beau mais
concrètement cantona des cultures à la
fin du mois n'a pas un centime pour
mettre du carburant dans son tracteur je
suis désolé un prêteur ne fonctionne pas
avec de l'eau de pluie donc un moment
donné tu as des problèmes de ce genre de
trésorerie carrément
c'est ça de trésorerie trésorerie alors
il ya les problèmes conjoncturels dont
font partie en fait les événements
climatiques dont le terme durable
justement il ya tout l'aspect
environnemental aspect climatique
l'aspect économique sociologique à
prendre en compte et je ne vois pas
aujourd'hui où est-ce que cet aspect là
est pris en compte je le répète encore
une fois nos amis de la guadeloupe ont
mis 4 millions d'euros sur la table
donc on voit quand même quand il ya une
volonté de faire quelque chose pour
l'agriculture de son pays
aujourd'hui nous au niveau de notre
syndicat
les jeunes agriculteurs ne nous battons
pour la transmission mais comment
prouver qu un jeune lui dis ok bon tu
vas tu installé sur un ou deux hectares
de terre tu trouves tu les trouves déjà
et puis pas un compte
tu n'auras pas un smic à la fin du mois
et puis tu travailles 30 jours par mois
ou 31 jours par mois sont l'appui elle
sous le soleil donc concrètement ce
salon aurait dû être une vitrine du
monde agricole et non pas en fait une
espèce de excusez moi le tiers mais de
mascarade pour en fait faire croire que
tout va bien alors que je suis désolé
les agriculteurs qui ont participé à ce
salon pour moi ils ont fait encore du
site et du bénévolat
je ne suis pas sûr que quand ils sont
tous rentrés chez eux ok ils ont
peut-être fait leur devoir en tant qu'
il fallait donner un coup de main ils
l'ont fait
mais concrètement est ce que c'est ce
qui leur a donné un pain à manger le
soir
monsieur dassier l'a bien dit li té sur
son exploitation parce que l'un
collaborateurs qui s'était blessé donc
les agriculteurs qui quittent on n'a pas
de forcément du temps
le vendredi le samedi le dimanche à
passer sur un salon alors que derrière
on ne sait pas on se gratte la tête
comment on va faire pour livrer je
prends un exemple d christophine parce
que les christophine ne se vendent plus
sur le marché local pourquoi parce que
guînes psychose à cause du chlordécone
ça quand est ce qu on en parle encore
une fois les guadeloupéens ils ont
réussi à avoir une aide pour tous quitté
reconversion par rapport au chlordécone
en martinique on en a pas donc nous ne
sommes pas là pour quémander ya pas de
dispositif comme une fantaisie positif
des de financement donc en fait on a une
bonification de financement sur les
fonds européens
maintenant on n'a jamais parlé
d'indemnisation ou quoi que ce soit on a
eu le plan cordes et compte 1 2 3 4 5 6
me suis même pas aux courriers tienne
nous sommes rendus je me pose des
questions
aujourd'hui on soit dit conscient c'est
de la production qu'on livre qui ne se
vend pas ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'à la fin du mois
c'est zéro euro de chiffre d'affaires et
que nous sommes nous savons tous
ensemble sur une île nous savons tous
que ce que nous mangeons
ça rend pas contenir qui en parle qui en
parlent à mieux que moi on n'est pas
forcément plus simple alors là quand ça
semble tout ça il me semble que tu as
gagné a dit ce qu'on appelle le salim
l'ancien répression des fraudes qui est
censé faire des analyses mais comme de
par hasard un le corps déconne a été
utilisé comme hunting seulement 1
les pommes de terre française tout va
très bien on va dire qu'elle rentre avec
leur tas de terreau ici mais on ne se
pose absolument pas la question de quel
produit qu'on utilise pour faire de la
patate france mais bon c'est pas grave
mais ce qu'on veut dire c'est qu'on ne
peut pas mettre en avant un salon pour
c'est pour moi c'est l'arbre qui cache
la forêt il ya un trop gros malaise dans
la profession agricole aujourd'hui pour
fair au salon et nous si j on se dit
qu'on n'y allait pas si qu'aujourd'hui
nous sommes en panne
l'installation est en panne ça veut dire
quoi se dire qu'il n'y a pas de
renouvellement de générations ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on a du
foncier qui part à vau l'eau
je n'en parle même pas le fond aussi
alors on va on va en parler le prochain
c'est notre prochain c'est notre
prochain sujet mais avant de parler de
du foncier du foncier non disponible
encore lapsus les choses n'ont guère
progressé c'est vrai notamment pour les
jeunes agriculteurs
christian d'agir est ce que à vous
entendre bon de l'agriculture
martiniquaise connaît connaît une crise
on peut dire ça la la la la crise et est
là depuis longtemps et elle ne
s'améliore pas ll s'aggraverait même
largeur que je veux
la crise je vais vous répondre d'abord
par deux chiffres après il y a une
vingtaine d'années
nous étions à 12 % des besoins
alimentaires bon à l'époque j'étais
d'une vice-présidence chamayou durée
avec vidic est née puis une équipe nous
rasions les murs dispense aujourd'hui
nous sommes à 4 % des besoins
alimentaires depuis un moment d'ailleurs
personne ne rasent les murs ça voilà je
pense qu'avec ça les gens comprennent ça
c'est un élément deuxième élément la
guadeloupe à une chambre d'agriculture
qui frappe sur la table et des élus qui
abdique
c'est normal vous êtes élu par le peuple
un élu il est au service du peuple
faut pas que les élus viennent faire son
petit cinéma la méprise et celui ci
faisait comme font beaucoup d'ailleurs
bon tu as parlé de l'ancien l'ancien
répression des fraudes à juste titre
yara pv aussi sachez et ça je ne
cesserai de répéter ça pourquoi tout le
monde rentre ça bien dans la tête que
des années 80 à 2000
moi je revenais tout frêle étudiants de
il y avait des contrôles qui se
faisaient sous tous les points de vente
de la menthe inique et même sur les
exploitations
je dis bien sûr tous les points de vente
1 c'est à dire sans exception aussi bien
dans la rue que dans les grandes
surfaces - 19 ans et qui s'étirera il y
avait également deux postes de contrôle
ports et aéroports
l'épaisseur des fraudes pv avec la
douane se passait des années 80 à 2000
une fois que le chlordécone est arrivé
tu as raison
les contrôles ont commencé à diminuer
comme par hasard mais nous sommes pas dû
on est pas des comics qu'on n'est pas
des plaisantins et je tire 10 qui que ce
soit et je suis très sévère sur sa de
rigoler avec ça tu as parlé du plan des
codes 1 2 et 3 millions ou 3 1 peut-être
qu'ils ont un quatrième mais on se moque
de nous mais on s'en moque de nous mais
pourquoi parce que ceux qui sont amenés
à représenter la radio martiniquaise
ce sont des comiques vous reprenez ils
ne sont et non mais j'ai pas fini non
non non j'ai pas fini
je n'ai pas je vous laisse finir mais
j'ai une question comme bwin avoir lâché
oui ça doit pas pourquoi parce qu'à au
fait ils n'ont pas pris la mesure
m ils sont là à faire des petits
sourires d'être comique et celles axées
sur des copies pour pouvoir et elle a
dit on n'arrive pas à vendre c'est une
réalité mais pourquoi n'at il pas avant
je vais vous dire pourquoi n'at il pas
ce sont ces services qui sont
régaliennes aïssi à la martinique qui
devrait recommencer à faire des
contrôles ce qui permettrait aux
agriculteurs qui fonctionne en
respectant la dot urologie agricole que
ça soit en culture raisonnée que ça soit
en cultures conventionnelles sont en
culture biologique ou organique 1
eh bien il ya il ya des normes de
conventionner la respecter et bien le
fait qu'il fasse les contrôles et bien
sa garantie ceux qui travaillent en
toute probité
ça permet à l'acheteur aussi bien vous
et c'est d'acheter en toute quiétude
mais comme lui pour être contrôle c'est
une réaction humaine tu as fait normal
c'est pas que les martiniquais sont
contre les martiniquais le martiniquais
c'est pas une imbécile il va il va ça
vient d'acheter puisqu'il n'ya pas de
contrôle il ne sait pas c'est pas bien y
amener moi car on dira que aller faire
des contrôles parce que ce que demandent
les services de l'état sous les
cocotiers à la martinique là et depuis
une dizaine d'années c'est quoi et bien
appelé nous pour dire que ba bertrand
car une voiture qui n'est pas que les
affaires de la prédation quiz des
rations de l'asvel on n'a pas ça à faire
mais moi je suis monté au créneau contre
ça alors il faudra et je termine sous ça
parce que je suis très sévère sur cette
affaire-là
il va falloir que les services de l'état
on commence à faire des contrôles et
nous mêmes on va pouvoir recommencer à
vendre nos produits en toute quiétude
et puis c'est et puis c'est ça bon et
puis un dernier élément là dessus du
jour il a même pas il n'y a pas de
contrôle ici les contrôles sans feu de
façon épisodique mais les produits qui
grand plat de la caraïbe et d'ailleurs
qui voit les miss dominique est
exactement ils sont contrôlés
une fois sur 10 ou deux fois au maximum
trois fois sur dix de manière aléatoire
voilà mais tout ça tout ça il est
pourtant à dire nous sommes de la
profession parce que demain matin
et puis je vais m'arrêter là dessus de
mater y aura un retour 1 1
un accident quelconque et caetera et
bien qu'est-ce qui va se reproduire
eh bien on va accuser les agriculteurs
moi je ne veux pas un être caution de
ceux qui vivent sous le cadavre 10 août
alors christian d'agir on va écouter
myriam leclerc d'ici quelques instants
mais comme vous exprimer que vous avez
dit vous êtes très sévère très sévère
rue
oui là dessus certains disent que vous
n'êtes pas le mieux placé pour parler de
chlordécone 2
de pollution 2-0 chlordécone un
pesticide parce que quand vous étiez
dans la banane vous êtes de ceux qui ont
utilisé le cur l'one est donc alors si
vous avez changé c'est très bien tant
mieux si vous avez viré écologistes pour
la paix l'agroécologie l'agro
agriculture tant mieux voilà alors je
réponds du sud de séoul où il faut
savoir que la culture ce qu'on veut noël
il faut savoir donc à vous êtes un
repenti non mais n'en ressentais de
l'utilisation de dépression
j'ai fait deux années que je récolte
évolué huit ans d'études en france remet
spécialisant et enfants ayant fait deux
spécialisations
j'ai choisi j'ai choisi avant même des
professionnels
j'ai choisi de pratiquer la culture
raisonnée
j'ai choisi ça donc partout où je suis
passé je fonctionnais avec la technique
de la culture raisonnée d'accord j'étais
un formateur pendant dx d'années jusqu'à
maintenant je la fais toujours celui
toujours des impératifs
j'ai toujours faire former les gens sous
tous les types de cultures et techniques
culturales mais alors en privilégiant la
culture raisonnée ça c'est un élément 1
donc même en production bananière quand
je gérais pour les mets qui et quand
j'avais ma propre exploitation
j'ai toujours fonctionné en culture
raisonnée ça c'est un élément deuxième
élément c'est sa culture raisonnée genre
d'explication à l'absence totale de
c'est la culture et auriez vous
expliquer bon et puis ça c'est pour ceux
qui bavent qui ont la bave du crapaud en
se voulant répondre ensuite ensuite
parallèlement à ça parce que j'ai une
exploitation à rivière salée et qui
existe depuis déjà une quarantaine
d'années j'ai toujours travaillé avec la
méthode de la culture organique
bon la culture raisonnée c'est quoi la
culture résonnait comme son nom
l'indiqué c'est à dire que vous êtes
amené ça vous demande dix fois plus de
travail car la culture conventionnelle
primo parce que vous êtes amené à
analyser systématiquement l'évolution
d'une maladie quelconque ce soir qui
doit ni cuneo des divers insectes
bon il ya des échelles pourquoi tout le
monde comprenne je vais prendre une tige
l2 une échelle de 100 si vous avez cinq
plans hâtez vous ne traitez pas ça c'est
la culture raisonnée mais vous
surveiller maintenant si vous passer le
stade des 30%
vous traitez par contre cultures
conventionnelles eh bien vous avez eu
sur 100 qui est atteint vous traiter
tous
voilà la différence à venir ça c'est pas
fini en plus de ça vous avez des
produits que vous utilisez des produits
pesticides que vous utilisez en culture
raisonnée que que vous n'utilisez pas en
cultures conventionnelles
il faut savoir cela et j'ai pu je
termine quand vous pouvez intégrer des
insectes en culture raisonnée également
donc ça c'est pour ceux qui ont la bave
du crapaud commun mais il fallait aussi
vous posez la question très venir vous
avez raison vous avez raison c'est qu'on
entend aussi quand on parle de vous mais
rien de clair
parmi les difficultés des agriculteurs
alors jeune ou moins jeune
il y a également je sais pas si c'est
encore valable à leur on parle au moment
où on parle du prix des intrants qui
sont très très coûteux plus coûteux oui
alors je
j'avoue je suis pas un grand spécialiste
de en la matière mais enfin il ya encore
pas mal de d'agriculteurs que soient
éleveurs ou articulteurs ou autres qui
disent on pète tout beaucoup trop cher
beaucoup plus cher surtout les intrants
par exemple des aliments comme le soja
aussi certains éleveurs se plaignent de
donc voilà il y a quelques années par
exemple on faisait 300 euros la tonne
intrants en france dans l'hexagone en
martinique 700 euros donc une voie là il
y avait une différence donc est-ce que
de ce point de vue là les choses se sont
améliorées ou pas ou est-ce que ça alors
justement pour répondre à votre question
mais aussi pour aller dans le sens d'un
chien en fait il faut savoir que les
intrants c'est un poste qui donc les
intrants sait tous les produits n'ont
pas besoin des fournitures me dit une
culture ou une et au nevada bien
aujourd'hui on s'est un peu on ne pourra
la société mais en fait il faut savoir
tout simplement ça coûte tellement cher
que les gens n'achètent pas quand je dis
que les gens n'achètent pas que les
agriculteurs même n'achètent pas et des
fois par abus de langage
j'aime à dire que l'agriculture
d'aujourd'hui où la digue lutter
fonctionne en bio parce que quand vous
avez un litre de produit phytosanitaire
qui approche les 500 600 euros et ce
n'est pas une blague c'est à dire que il
faut savoir que nous sommes considérés
comme un marché d'intérêt mais ma
seconde et un tuner
c'est à dire que pour les grosses firmes
phytopharmaceutiques ils n'ont pas
s'amuser à développer un produit pour
l'entracte nos sur l'igname par exemple
parce que de toutes les façons ce n'est
que quelques petits milliers d'hectares
qui traîne comme ça dans le monde donc
ils sont pas intéressés donc lice le si
peu de produit qui existe déjà un ce ne
sont pas des produits qui sont forcément
adapté à nos cultures donc ils sont
homologués sur nos cultures ils ne sont
pas forcément adaptées et en plus le
coût n'est même pas exorbitant est
prohibitif veut dire qu'ils calent
agriculteurs va aller acheter un produit
qui at je ne sais pas combien de
centaines d'euros le litre bon
disponibles
c'est aberrant donc aujourd'hui la
plupart des agriculteurs cherchent des
solutions alternatives et se tournent
donc vers des solutions beaucoup plus
organique on va dire avec de
l'association de culture ou autres ils
vont beaucoup utilisé justement tout ce
qui est partenaire donc les des insectes
où ils vont utiliser cette bonne chose
elle est ni sortie du clip que devant
l'incapacité financière a à faire
honnêtement hé ben du coup au final de
compte ça on ne le dit pas suffisamment
mais là des cultures devient quasiment
bio jeudi guy quasiment puisque
aujourd'hui une tonne d'engrais coûte
tellement cher que maintenant les
agriculteurs commencent à revenir
finalement au bon vieux fumier et puis
aussi non au compost est à dire que tout
le monde est en train de chialer sur
internet si c'est pas plus mal pour eux
c'est pas des consommateurs pour le
prime c'est plus difficile pour le tour
du cou pour l'agriculteur ou est ce que
je gagne selon l'afe sont obligés on l'a
fait par dépit et c'est ce qui n'est pas
bon a dit qu'on ne choisit jamais une
solution et subissent inc squat elle par
dépit ça dit ok si on le faisait dans
monsieur monsieur d'agir a parlé d'aller
cultures conventionnelles et autres en
fait si on le faisait dans un itinéraire
qui étaient dictées c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui la des cultures quand il
va dans un magasin dans une enseigne
quand il regarde le prix du produit se
gratte la tête il repart du magasin et
puis se dit bon ben tant pis ils
préfèrent des fois arraché sa culture
parce que ça coûte moins cher
aujourd'hui d'arracher deux mille mètres
carrés de concombres que de s'amuser à
traiter de métal de concours mais puis
de ne même pas être sûr de savoir si on
un résultat ou pas donc oui les intrants
sont excessivement chers aujourd'hui on
n'a pas le choix on est obligé de le
faire on est tout le temps tout le temps
tout le temps dans le système d je ne
parle même pas de l'agrofourniture
aujourd'hui en termes d'équipement on va
des différentiels quasiment 2 50% à 10
ans contre une machine qui coûte 6 euros
john oui on est ici il faut quasiment
multiplié le prix par deux alors on va
me dire oui l'octroi de mer oui le court
le coude approche wepad économies
d'échelle ok mais ce que c'est à nous
agriculteurs dessus billon seul 1 ce
n'est pas à nous de subir cela
donc il faut aussi qu'à un moment donné
comme crise on assure le disait il faut
qu'il y ait une véritable politique
agricole adapté à la martinique à dire
qu'on ne peut pas tout le temps être
ingénieux et puis en même temps se faire
taper dessus par l'état se faire taper
dessus par les consommateurs et un à un
moment donné un agriculteur réseau
d'agriculteurs m tanguay même que comme
je dis tout un agriculteur c'est une
boîte à outils et pour mensura parce que
on doit être météo roulotte puisqu'un
comme la météo n'est pas capable de
prévoir compter sur un mauvais temps
c'est à nous lever le nez de savoir s'il
faut qu'on sorte me pompe ou pas de la
région parce que quand on perd une pompe
ses 5000 euros et je signale aux
personnes qui se gargarisent tout le
temps que les agriculteurs roule en pick
up
ce n'est pas pour moi j'aurais préféré
rouler en berline de vie ça me coûterait
moins cher en tenue donc c'est pas pour
rien on a des on a des traces
aujourd'hui dès qu'il ya un mauvais
temps et b je ne vois pas je ne vois pas
comment on fait pour info arrivée sur
l'exploitation donc on est obligé
d'avoir des pick up
quand il ya un mauvais temps n'est pas
prévu on n'a pas à retirer la peau de
pick up contribuer à l'entêtement à
l'absence de trésorerie quelquefois dû
lutter concrètement même si ses suprises
sur la société me demandant comment on
fait pour atteindre nos exploitations
aujourd'hui on doit être aussi invité
finir alors vous parlez des êtres en des
produits vétérinaires aujourd'hui c'est
une catastrophe une catastrophe
alors que on a réussi à éradiquer
quasiment l'attique sénégalaise moi je
mettrais le bio puisque aujourd'hui pour
des tickets les boeufs quand il faut
acheter un produit phytopharmaceutique
ça coûte excessivement cher
au final compte c'est toujours les mêmes
qui ont les capacités d'achat n'est pas
nocive alors question d'agir on va pas
refaire le même constat le ça a été
assez édifiant ce que vient de nous
expliqué myriam leclerc mais quelle
solution est ce qu'il faut effectivement
complètement oublié on ne peut pas non
plus complètement se passer de
n'apporter certain nombre de produits à
des produits qu'on est obligé de de
faire venir qu'on ne trouve pas sur
place
même si elle dit bron s'adapte les
agriculteurs s'adapte font quasiment du
bio en subissant cette situation des
intrants beaucoup trop cher alors je
vais pas reprendre ce qu'elle a dit
parce que là elle a été très pédago
voilà et je partage mais quelles sont la
présentation la piste la piste c'est
encore on revient au même dénominateur
la chambre d'agriculture
c'est son dada
non mais non mais non mais non mais
attendez moi vous savez quoi je suis un
gars très pratique
j'ai une formation technique et
scientifique je suis très pratique je
vais toujours droit au but toutes les
manifestations ecall que j'ai mené vous
avez des voisins étaient elles ont été
sonnantes et trébuchantes mais droit au
but bon je vais pas bloquer la ville
et puis j'ai besoin j'ai un problème
avec voir réglé je vais pas bloqué 28
points bien non je vais je vous tiens je
vous sais qu'elles subissent et tout ça
avec vous je donc c'est comme ça le
problème
il vient de la chambre d'agriculture de
la politique et non pas des employés de
la chambre de la politique de rachat et
culture qui est absente ce qu'elle vient
de dire là c'est une super démonstration
eux les produits les intrants aussi bien
pour les animaux comme les végétaux ils
sont pas adaptés à la martinique c'est
une réalité déjà ça c'est un 1er mai si
la vie politique forte en demandant
parce qu'il ya des gens ici qui sont
prêts à s'investir en demandant à ce que
que se console en ch'ti un besoin il ya
un besoin
1 et puis qu'on fabrique nos produits
est ce qu'on peut vraiment pas ce qu'il
faut savoir de façon artisanale mais oui
monsieur carouge et de façon artisanale
et bien de façon artisanale
il y à des agriculteurs jeudi mais c'est
artisanal qui produit qui fabrique des
produits phyto sanitaires nature est il
y en a il faut savoir et moi-même moi
même puisque je forme toujours et bien
j'apprends aux gens à bien connaître
justement les différents éléments
principaux et secondaires et tertiaires
naturel donc
ça c'est ça qu'il faut encourager c'est
ça qu'il faut faire face à une autre
échelle oui mais ça c'est une politique
d'action voici la solution est comme ça
et comme ça faut pas oublier que nous
sommes une île
nous sommes une île d'accord donc ce qui
fait que lorsque vous dépendez de ce qui
vient de l'extérieur qui vous empoisonne
et que ça n'arrive pas et que vous êtes
bloqué puis avec tout tout tout tout ce
qu'elle vient développer que tu des
réalités qu'il faut prendre en compte eh
bien vous êtes amené à le faire et ça
coûte 100 fois moins cher ça c'est un
élément deux éléments désagréments qui
est très important il y a une beauté au
logis d'accord pour quel que soit le
type de culture ont choisi mais des fois
qu'il n'est pas respecté
mais il faut le dire il faut le dire
donc ce qui fait que il ya les dérives
mais ça aussi il faut le dire
vous comprenez et c'est tout ça ça joue
le temps à tout cela et bien qu'on
trouve une agriculture difficile sachez
qu auparavant il y avait entre 10000 et
sept mille agriculteurs aujourd'hui on
est à peine à 3 milliards des cultures
aujourd'hui et ça a été vite en moins de
20 ans il ya eu cette grosse chute là
mais ça c'est pas parce que les gens ne
s'intéressent pas là elle a fait une
belle démonstration la ligne dure n'est
pas un idiot qu'il soit jeune ou moins
jeune
il n'est pas nice n'est pas un imbécile
il réfléchit au regard d y réfléchir
c'est terrible oui mais c'est pour tout
ça rapporte gros à perdre et tout le
temps quand vous vivez comme ça fait le
travail
c'est pour que vous puissiez vivre au
quotidien suez quand vous êtes là comme
ça là à être à être surprise mais en
plus de ça a dit je termine rapidement
pendant la vie que tu as fait de la
grimace
les vendeurs date quand il sourit ils
ont un beau sous les vendeurs d'un train
d'être rude vous comprenez donc il ya un
problème profond là les intrants même si
c'est par des coopératives des
groupements d'exploitants qui ça ne fait
pas tellement baissé le prix c'est le
parler en face à ce niveau là en fait
l'idée c'est vraiment justement de créer
de véritables filières intégrées
c'est à dire aller de l'amont jusqu'à
laval et couvrir tout le champ
aujourd'hui quand on me parle par
exemple de soja pour les animaux je
rigole je dis attendez soyons sérieux
ici on nous sommes dans un pays tropical
humide on a de la pluie on l'a du soleil
les repoussent à profusion
j'ai envie de dire où est ce qu'il est
le problème colomb de neurones
réfléchissons d'importer du soja nourris
mais nous nous avions des pneus dans la
douleur 2 au même s'il me alimi ok ya
pas d mais il ya du soleil et ya deux il
ya deux appuis jusqu'à maintenant tous
les cas ça a toujours fonctionné un bon
on va me dire oui il ya des problèmes de
deux périodes de sécheresse le carême
tous les cas moi enfin nous là autour de
la table voler tous les matins et on
voit qu'il pleut et il ya du soleil
l'herbe pousse on a ainsi que deux des
hommes normalement ses 28 jours ont
maintenu je ne suis pas je ne crois pas
je ne suis pas très sûr que ce soit 28
jours
bref on tout ça pour dire que je pense
qu'on a suffisamment d'ingénierie
suffisamment de technicité aujourd'hui
nous sommes en 2018 pour créer et
développer des filières 1 on a je ne
sais pas combien de pourcentage de
chômage chez les jeunes crayons des
filières qui permettent de produire des
intrants pour la dea culture
martiniquaise pareil maintenant on a
développé de nouvelles solutions pour
confronter les végétaux par exemple on
fait du choix que du purin d'ortie donc
en fait on me dit on met des outils à
macérer et ensuite on offrir aux cieux
voilà et on traite en fait après les
plantes avec ça ben essayons de voix
aussi à moigné je dis aussi un moyen de
le faire à plus grande échelle il me
semble qu on a le campus amour
environnementale caribéen le cake
donc il regroupe le cirad plus d'autres
organismes mais à ce moment là messieurs
dames j'ai envie de dire quand on veut
aller en martinique a arrêté de
réfléchir à lesage et puis réfléchissez
aux véritables problématiques de nos
agriculteurs ce n'est pas normal
qu'aujourd'hui ce soit des électeurs qui
sont obligés de faire des
expérimentations
donc on est tout le temps là une potion
magique pareils à des agriculteurs je
sais qu'ils ont essayé de mettre de
l'eau de mer sur les sur les bovins pour
faire tomber les tic
c'est aberrant quand même que personne
ne s'y intéresse
à un moment donné intéressons nous voir
si ça fonctionne
si ça fonctionne pas si ça fonctionne on
valide effectivement tout ce que je suis
en train de dire là ça demande une
véritable politique des rir mais il n'y
est pas en tous les cas normal que ce
soit aux agriculteurs d'être ingénieur
en expérimentation d'être ingénieur
production et geignant commercialisation
et puis aussi on leur demande maintenant
de cet acheteur à l'international
puisque les intrants qu'on soit bien
d'accord ce sont des comme auditeur je
parle de commodité ce terme un peu
technique mais en fait ce sont des deux
grandes masses qui sont qu'on achète sur
le marché international un compte où va
acheter par exemple une tonne de soja il
faut savoir que ça va dépendre de ce qui
se passe au brésil cela dépend de
comment la chine a éternué
si trop billy comptons pas enfin et vous
pensez qu'un agriculteur lui il comprend
ça c'est à dire que au niveau de son
exploitation
aujourd'hui ils achètent une tonne de
soja elle était à 500 euros et puis de
mai le moins après il rode boom la tonne
de soja coûte 1200 euros on va lui
expliquer oui vous savez le contexte
international
pat à tenir le gars il se dit juste lol
arrêtez de me fait rigoler de seconde
trouver une solution puisque comme la
tonne de soja coûte 50 euros
bizarrement vous n'aurez percuté jamais
les prix à la baisse
alors je veux bien que quand on augmente
vous augmentiez mais quand ça baisse
plus que le cours le cours de la bourse
même si métier d'agriculteur ne soient
des grands grecque
il regarde quand même un tout petit peu
la télévision il sait très bien qu'au
cours de la bourse n'est pas linéaire et
est séparée qui monte qu'à mon tel cas
décembre mais quand ça descend ce serait
intéressant que c'est notre chien
fournisseurs diminue aussi le prix on va
jamais publié allez vous voulez ajouter
quelque chose en deux phrases question
d'acheter ces médias il y a le piment il
ya également le charbon qui sont qui
sont des éléments naturels qu'on met en
décoction et qui peuvent traiter aussi
bien sur le plan des insectes que sur le
plan des cryptogrammes voilà ce que je
voulais apporter une tonne d'engrais je
faisais le calcul en coûte une tonne
d'engrais 1 coûte 2800 euros
on a alors parmi les perspectives pour
l'agriculture martiniquaise certains
avancent l'agriculture biologique
alors est-ce que elle peut être
développée en martinique
quelles conditions surtout que l' agence
nationale
française lagence bio vient de dire que
dans l'outre-mer le bio ne se développe
pas beaucoup
et je crois que pour la martinique c'est
moins de 2 % des surfaces agricoles qui
sont consacrées au bio logika
l'agriculture bio alors bon fausse piste
faux espoirs où il faut y aller il faut
y aller mais il faut y aller beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus franchement je sais
pas qui veut répondre peut-être ailleurs
secrétaire général de des jeunes
agriculteurs rien cynique mais en fait
non se dit au niveau des géants tous les
cas il s'agit là on ne veut pas opposer
deux types d'agricultures ni de de deux
catégories d'agriculteurs le bio aussi
bien que le conventionnel le
conventionnel aussi bien que le bio les
deux se valent au chili deux se valent
c'est que ils ont toutes les deux la
même fonction la première fonction c'est
de nourrir le peuple
après il faut savoir qu'un agriculteur
est soumis à des règles d'ailleurs un à
des cultures conventionnelles doit
passer ce qu'on appelle le certiphyto
donc le certiphyto si un certificat qui
permet en fait d'utiliser des produits
phytosanitaires de façon le plus le plus
adapté que possible et c'est pour ça que
moi j'invite la population à acheter
dans des dissidents les circuits tracés
à de la traçabilité
parce que en dehors on ne sait pas ce
qui se passe effectivement tous les
agriculteurs sont soumis aux lmr donc on
fameuse limite résiduelles voilà
exactement ça ça on l'apprend ça fait
partie du campus de base
après c'est vrai que l'agriculture
biologique
aujourd'hui il ya une forte demande on
ne peut pas le nier mais en aidant des
contextes tropicaux je viens de le dire
ce n'est vraiment pas évident de
demander aujourd'hui à la bonne foi un
développement de l'agriculture bio c'est
qu'est ce qui est dit a droit n'est pas
sonné la mobilisation sinon pas du tout
l'avis la difficulté en fait c'est que
aujourd'hui contre un agriculteur va se
lancer dans le bio c'est au niveau de
l'impact du revenu c'est à dire qu'il
aura du mal à faire sortir une culture
viable dans la viabilité j'entends quoi
j'entends que effectivement ya la
qualité donc à kallithea des présentes
mais la quantité
nous sommes dans l'ensemble dans un pays
tropical donc nous sommes impactés par
toutes sortes de maladies
il faut savoir que dès lors qu'on
commence à faire une culture en intensif
donc intensif ça veut dire sur de
grandes surfaces
on a beaucoup de choses d'être impactée
par une maladie soit par rapport à des
insectes soit par rapport à des
champignons ou autre donc c'est très
difficile pour un agriculteur
aujourd'hui d'avoir des revenus adaptés
pour pau pour nourrir sa famille pour
nourrir ce pour payer ses charges pardon
et tout ce qui s'ensuit
voilà vous christian d'agir alors membre
du collectif 0 club zéro chlordécone
zéro pesticide l'agriculture biologique
elle peut elle doit même à vos yeux
certainement en tout cas je vous pose la
question
elle doit certainement être développé en
martinique les conditions sont elles
réunies
jean rejoint myriam vous m'excuserez
mais c'est très bien rappelons que vous
n'êtes pas du même syndicat vous non
fécondé puis je n'avais que nous on a le
choix d'aller soit l'opa soit la savoie
et puis peut-être
codema modef mais voilà il ya trois
choix peut-être rejoindra-t-elle à
l'opam qui sait si elle vient que ce
jour là elle sera très bien et sera là
elle le sait alors ils le savent alors
l'agriculture biologique allah dieu
maîtres mots là que je reprends et que
je partage
il n'est pas question d'opposer la
culture conventionnelle la culture
raisonnée et la culture bio et la
culture organique et de n'est pas
question par contre 9,0 que des cônes
zéro pesticide façon pour des cons moi
je suis pour que cela se fasse au niveau
de l'assiette
elle vient me dit tout à l'heure que
nous sommes là pour nourrir le peuple au
niveau de l'assiette niveau de
l'assiette
et quand je dis au niveau de la scène
ces gens retournent au cours sur notre
aîné mort il faut que les services en
italie qui se grattent 1 et qui sont
sous les cocotiers
s'il s'ils font leur travail si on
permettait au lieu de travail et bien
c'est sûr et certain que le consommateur
n'y aura dans son assiette un produit
sans traces de pesticides
parce que il y en a parlé tout à l'heure
de deux conventions il ya il y à il ya
des conventions à respecter il ya des
normes à respecter
si ces normes sont respectées et bien
aucun problème kibio qui pas bio il ya
aucun problème vous n'aurez pas de plus
mais quand les normes ne sont pas
respectées ou des raisons x y z que je
cautionne pas et que tu que ce n'est pas
non plus d'ailleurs
et bien c'est sûr et certain il faut il
faut il faut que vous soyez frappé pour
vous soyez pénalisé comme soyez dénoncer
mais le seul qui peut faire ça et j'ai
six dessus c'est pour ça que je parle
très fortement la se sont laissés à
visual l'état et une bonne de salopards
ils ne font pas leur travail
convenablement qui fait que nous sommes
en difficulté nous les agriculteurs
parce que moi qui travail convenablement
3 qui travail convenablement et les sens
qui travail convenablement
eh bien nous sommes pénalisés pourquoi
parce qu'il ya un vide les bons paie
aussi pour revenir au chlordécone le
zéro pesticide dans l'est dans les
assiettes oui à une seule et unique
mission c'est que les services de l'état
fasse son travail convenablement
convenable mais comme on dirait
l'agriculture biologique
à vous entendre c'est pas c'est pas la
panacée quoi en fait alors ça peut venir
à côté d'autres choses mais c'est le
passé pour vous c'est pas l'avenir de la
lorelei effet calmant vous avez bien sûr
de me re ne me relancer en fait tu as
bien fait du toit cabinet fondement
lancées dessus alors la culture
biologique elle à el milia m'a dit
quelque chose de très fort je vais pas
citer une agriculture que je connais
très bien connaissez très bien qui est
un an culture en culture raisonnée et
ensuite il est passé en culture
biologique et heal africa load sûr qu'à
l'autre et un jour il m'a décrit si tu
sais j'ai arrêté avec le bio parce que
mon appel dans l'autre baguette c'est
bon et moi même j'ai étudié le bio que
j'étais étudiant aggravantes en bon mais
c'est le choix je suis pas contre le bio
mais il faut savoir il ya beaucoup qui
ne savent pas 57 en bio elle a parlé du
talent heures de la culture intensive
mais faut pas que les gens prennent le
mauvais temps s'ils font quelque chose
de 1
quand vous faites une culture maintenant
on oppose permaculture à culte mais ça
on va y arriver de la pharma culture
alors que pourra rapidement vous êtes
vous à passagère mine c'est déjà presque
film est nominé faux pas est finie vous
avez déjà à nourrir vous avez déjà à
nourrir il ya 400 4 380 mille habitants
à martigues il ya plus 150 comme
auparavant
il faut que vous produisez de façon
régulière et et intensive quel que soit
le choix que vous avez choisi bon il
vous faut en bio la même surface là
pourquoi parce que quand vous avez une
surface plantée il ya ce qu'on appelle
dans le jargon vous créer un foyer
bon mais il vous faut une surface pour
parce que vous n'avez pas traitées donc
il faut voir ce que vous créiez plus
rapidement la rotation du vide sanitaire
et beaucoup échouent sur sa tendance à
se dire quoi en bio si vous avez besoin
si on a besoin de nectar ou deux dans
d'autres types de cultures pour vivre
décemment
ambiance folle à double puisqu'il à
haute tension de la culture est beaucoup
plus rapide
un jeu d'enfant avec moi c'est ça vous
comprenez mais il faut qu'il y ait du
bio la mantide mais faut pas oublier une
chose non plus ce que nous sommes petite
île et nous sommes emballés par des
alizés donc en 1981 et pendant longtemps
je disais à la chambre aux îles font qu'
il va falloir et ça c'est une politique
agricole ont qu il va falloir raisonnée
réserver des zones bio à la martinique
parce que regarder quelques provinces
prie et fume et un petit des zozos un
petit déodorants et bien 500 mètres plus
loin
vous prenez l'odeur du daeu doit donc
avec les alizés
c'est bien que nous avons réalisé je ne
critique pas les alizés mais il faut l'a
dit tout à l'heure il faut adapter tout
il va falloir réserver les fausses et
demi c'est très bien moi j'ai déjà
affirmé sa en plan d un mot porc
beaucoup font 7 nice et anne hanzal et
pendant les parties du nord à la
caravelle etc
ou alors choisir et qu'on sait qu'on a
on s'installe dans une commune
on sait que dans ces communes l'a aimé
c'est bio bouffer parce que bon c'est un
exemple alors il reste cinq minutes à
peine le démission donc c'est bien on a
fait le tour on a compris tout le monde
ne pourra pas faire du bio mais vous
êtes pour réserver certaines zones
certaines régions au bio là où c'est
peut-être le moins vente il est enfin là
où il ya le moins saisissant même mais
bon les ont fait du bio là il faut c'est
de nous et c'est ces enclaves et
géographiquement pas s'il ya beaucoup de
si mais c'est très bien et fasse du bio
et s'il y avait une politique agricole
on aurait dit bon ben là on fait du bio
la rivière salée par exemple on décide
on fait du mur par exemple et puis en
fait que du bio et là il ya une plus
grande garantie très bien alors oui non
mais on a compris que il faudra en faire
mais tout le monde le poids ne pourra
pas en faire c'est pas forcément la
panacée
autres pistes de développement pour
rés comment dirais-je diminué peut-être
voire même résorber la crise que
connaissent nos agriculteurs c'est le
tourisme rural
le tourisme rural ça
alors c'est des jeunes agriculteurs est
ce que vous y croyez est ce que là
encore ces gens me disent sceptiques
c'est quand même si comme le bio c'est à
dire qu'il faut de tout pour faire un
monde
nous avons des collègues agriculteurs
jeunes ou pas jeunes ils font du bio ils
font du tourisme aura les façons nous
sommes obligés de diversifier mais en
tous les cas la faune ont conclu au oui
il ya quelques années il ya une dizaine
d'années me semble qu'on faisait cent
mille tonnes on produisait cent mille
tonnes de denrées en martinique comme
monsieur d'achiet le dit si bien
aujourd'hui on en produit je ne sais que
je ne veux même plus savoir quels sont
les chiffres
je ne veux plus je me suis arrêté quand
on a atteint la barre des 20000 quel que
soit ce qu'on va faire un petit chute du
nombre d'agriculture d'agriculteurs
chute j'ai eu à la production de la
duchère quelque chose moi tu besoin au
niveau des besoins des ventes et quelle
que soit la piste qu'on va retenir une
tourisme rural bio collège est urgent de
remonter les quantités de denrées
végétales produites à la martinique et
ça je le martèle les gens ne vont pas
manger des gîtes des bungalows ça ne se
mange pas et quand on va faire venir des
touristes
ça me tue je vous le dis ça me tue
on leur donne dans leurs assiettes des
frites avec des pommes de terre de
france c'est accroissement ridicule donc
avec some gdg dgd nous avons des
collègues qui prône un tourisme rural
donc effectivement qui produisit qui
propose les produits de la ferme
ça demande énormément d'investissement
et je ne veux pas aujourd'hui que les
gens comprennent que le tourisme rural
ce serait la force de forte sinon la
porte de sortie c'est que on les une
politique qui nous permet de produire de
vendre nos produits sur notre marché et
ensuite oui on verra pour accueillons du
monde et pour donner à toutes les
personnes tous nos visiteurs tous ces
bateaux de touristes qui viennent en
martinique
qu'ils repartent avec des tomates et de
la laitue du concours de la viande
en fait tout ce qui est produit possible
d'être produit localement il faut
recommencer à produire c'est l'urgence
merci myriam leclerc exploitante
agricole secrétaire général d'ugt
dix cas ce jeune agriculteur de
martinique le mot de la fin pour vous
christian d'agir sur le tourisme rural
elle a dit déjà beaucoup de choses mais
vous je partage ce lundi matin je pense
aussi un petit peu quand même sinon elle
l'a bien dit ça il a dit qu'il faut de
tout mais ce n'est pas la panacée c'est
passionnant c'est sûr qu'on va régler
les problèmes mais on doit éviter deux
ans donc je partage ce qu'elles viennent
de dire là est par contre j'ai ajoute un
élément principal
il est temps qu'il y ait une politique
agricole claires nettes et précises à la
menthe il y aura des élections bientôt à
la sono et une élection j'espère que
j'espère que les gens seront reçus ou
s'ils vont se réveiller et puis plus de
façon à pouvoir mettre des femmes et des
hommes qui ont qui ont de quoi dans la
tête pour pouvoir balancer une
agriculture adaptée à la matinée merci
merci à vous myriam leclerc bien sûr
d'agir d'avoir participé à ce face à la
première spéciale l'agriculture
martiniquaise on a vu qui connaît une
crise ya des difficultés mais tout n'est
pas perdu et on renvoie vous avez des
idées justement vous en avez fait pas au
cours de cette émission
à bon entendeur salut bon week-end à
tous
face à la première
[Musique]